on m'a acheté rire en se promenant dans
la forêt il y est tombé par hasard sur
un endroit tout à fait charmant un
cimetière pour animaux
c'est un endroit où on enterre son
animal pour pas oublier ça peut faire
peur mais y'a pas de raison c'est
complètement naturel quand la mort est
naturelle
le club il utilise cet endroit depuis
des générations
les gens en ont fait une sorte de rituel
c'est pas des histoires j'ai vu ce
symbole sur les arbres c'est un
avertissement
les indiens qui vivaient là les ont
gravé avant de fuir
vous avez peur de cet endroit quelque
chose habitent cette foire est quelque
chose qui remonte à très loin
quelque chose à qui ces terres
appartiennent quelque chose le ça était
mort qui fait revenir à la vie charts
[Musique]
je sais ce que vous voulez faire mais
quand ils reviennent ils ne sont plus
les mêmes
bah oui ce qu'est ce qui se passait
rostov j'aurais jamais dû vous montrer
cet endroit c'est pas seulement votre
enfant qui va revenir
la barrière est brisé
on a une seconde chance parfois il ya
pire que la mort
[Applaudissements]